justin trudeau aurait voulu être en mode
grande séduction auprès de la population
indienne
mais ces plans ont déraillé dès le début
de la journée chasse pas la toile c'est
cet homme canadienne une photo prise
cette semaine lors d'une soirée en
l'honneur du cinéma indien air mumbai et
ils étaient invités à une grande
réception prévue aujourd'hui à la
résidence officielle du haut commissaire
du canada ronen c'est une situation que
nous prenons très au sérieux
évidemment la personne en question
n'aurait jamais dû être évité et dès
qu'on a su ce qui se passait on a retiré
l'invitation
pourtant jasp à la toile a été condamné
pour une tentative d'assassinât de
ministres indiens en 1986 sur l'île de
vancouver il faisait alors partie d'un
groupe de séparatistes sig déclaré
illégal au canada et ailleurs
ce qui rend la sphère particulièrement
embarrassant pour justin trudeau
c'est que c'est un de ses propres
députés et président du caucus libéral
de la colombie-britannique branding
sarraï qui a fourni son nom pour qu'il
soit inscrit à la liste d'invités
le député responsable d'avoir inclus
cette personne j'en assume l'entière
responsabilité
on aime justin trudeau fait parler de
lui mais pas pour les raisons qui
l'auraient souhaité geoffrey dit liu
kong
cette controverse ne pouvait pas plus
mal tomber
où l'on met sa rencontre avec le
ministre en chef du pendjab où jusqu'à
ce que vous pensez avoir remis les
pendules à l'heure son la position
canadienne au sujet du mouvement
séparatiste sic et à la veille de son
tête à tête avec le premier ministre n'a
rennes rameau 10 pour ceux qui
accusaient justin trudeau de passer des
vacances en famille en inde
eh bien les derniers jours n'ont pas été
une partie de plaisir
et si madeleine la mort à radio canada
new delhi